[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur lefigaro.fr
nouveau numéro de points de vue et des
points de vue fort tranché et on
l'espère aussi opposé que passionnant
tous les cas il ya le casting pour
bonsoir andré bercoff bonsoir essayiste
journaliste et créateur d'une web télé
la france libre il a tout compris
d'ailleurs il est ce soir sur figaro
live tout comme georges et kuzmanovic
bonsoir vous êtes on voit dans une autre
boite télé mais qui est radicalement de
l'autre côté de la rive
en tous les cas le média vous êtes
ancien officier et conseiller de jean
luc mélenchon sur les questions
internationales et également de sécurité
bonsoir marc landré bonsoir rédacteur en
chef et communes france au figaro et
habitués bien sûr le figaro live tout
comme karine becquart bonsoir
journaliste au service politique de
france inter vous avez longtemps couvert
la droite ça tombe bien parce que ce
soir on va s'intéresser à la droite à la
droite de la droite
de l'autre côté des alpes avec une
question que faire face aux défis posés
par le gouvernement italien ils refusent
la réforme des accords de dublin il veut
s'occuper seule de ces programmes
d'immigration
qu'en pensez vous donnez votre avis et
répondez à notre question twitter alors
que l'italie ferme ses portes aux
migrants aguila merkel appelle à la
création d'une agence européenne de
l'immigration
soutenez-vous sa proposition en france
les syndicats doivent t'ils jeter
l'épongé
le sénat vient d'adopter la réforme de
la sncf nous on vous pose une question
sur twitter êtes vous pour ou contre un
arrêt de la grève à la sncf
voter pour voter contre mais votez et
surtout donnez nous votre avis autre
question que faire face au boycott des
produits israéliens de plaintes ont été
déposées par le crif après des actions
commando et coups de poing dans des
supermarchés
dites nous ce que vous en pensez et
poser vos questions à nos invités et
enfin faut-il renoncer à sauver la
maison de pierre loti sos racisme et
l'uejf dénonce des écrits de l'auteur du
mythique pêcheurs d'islande
on vous pose la question donnez nous
votre avis poser vos questions c'est
votre émission se sont aussi vos points
de vue et on va s'occuper et on va
s'intéresser d'abord par le parti à la
séparation à israël
israélienne va je pense que les avis
vont pas dire les avis risque d'être
branché mais unanime est ici mon cher
marc c'est une émission de débat
contradictoire est donc question que
faire face au défi italien sauf surprise
les parlementaires italiens vont adoubé
le nouveau gouvernement tout à l'heure à
rome sauf surprise la délégation chargée
de représenter le ministre de
l'intérieur et chef de la ligue du nord
matteo salvini votera non au projet de
réforme des accords de dublin que
l'europe le sache
les italiens ont décidé de décider seuls
de leur politique d'immigration et
matteo salvini a donné un aperçu ce
dimanche lors d'un déplacement en sicile
de ce que ça pourrait donner vie pour
loger alt a dit bigras qui rit golan est
élevé nono nier il met à primer les plus
correct vidéos seront publiés peggy lee
grady clandestine et infinite à la pape
qui a préparé
[Applaudissements]
et en france voici ce qu'en pense
nicolas dupont aignan il était l'invité
ce matin de jean michel aphatie et bruce
toussaint sur france info il faut
rétablir les contrôles dans tous les
pays il faut une double coque
les bateaux qui tiennent la mer ont une
double coque la coque nationale des
contrôles nationaux c'est ce que je
propose je vous fais remarquer jean
michel aphatie que 80 % des français y
sont favorables
rétablir les contrôles aux frontières
devrait contrôler totalement fi totale
et ils font comme ça sera avec son poing
droit qui est de l'élection européenne
les français devront trancher ce point
et puis il faut aussi une coopération
européenne alors en matière de
coopération européenne voici ce qu'en
pense la ministre chargée de la question
au gouvernement on est copule nathalie
oiseaux était invité de rtl ce matin
on ne te traiter la question des
demandes d'asile qu'au niveau européen
en harmonisant les critères en
harmonisant les procédures angola merkel
ce week-end s'est dit favorable à une
agence européenne
une agence européenne de la ligne ça
changerait le fait qu'on est tous les
mêmes critères les mêmes procédures les
mêmes durée d'examen des demandes
d'asile ce qui existe que les passeurs
joug d'une législation par rapport à une
autre
alors je salue arnaud qu'il nous
rejoindre sur le forum du figaro.fr vous
posez vos questions et vous répondez à
notre question twitter alors que
l'italie ferme ses portes aux migrants
angela merkel appelle à la création
d'une agence européenne de l'immigration
soutenez-vous sa proposition et vous
georgios monolithique mais dans ce
domaine comme dans d'autres une
européenne
j'ai extrêmement mal les choses et il
laisse les pays les plus exposés aux
migrations que sont l'italie et la grèce
se débrouillent comme ils peuvent
tout cela est aggravé avec le système de
la double isation qui est tragique
donc la dualisation on précise c'est
quand un migrant arrive dans un pays
européen
c'est lui qui doit c'est ce pays
européen qui doit s'occuper du cas de ce
mur ans et 6e migrants va dans un autre
pays européen se paie l'autre pays
européen peut renvoyer vers le pays
européens d'origine si vous n'avez pas
compris que vous
et vos questions ont leur précisera
voilà et donc les migrants relève plutôt
du côté de la grèce l'italie le danemark
est bien évidemment ça va créer des
drames humains terrible avec même des
jeunes qui des gens qui se brûlent les
les
les doigts les pour le club parce que
c'est les empreintes sur les moyens de
retrouver par où ils sont rentrés au
comptant - des situations totalement
inhumaine et là on vient surtout le
caractère inhumain tout le monde est
d'accord mais vous pensez qu'il faut là
c'est très clair aujourd'hui est ce qui
est une réponse européenne une réponse
nationale
il faut il faudrait une réponse
européenne si on avait une capacité
d'avoir une assise internationale la
cité n'a pas donc il faut avoir une
réponse nationale et et coopérer de
mieux possible et on vous avoir veillé à
ce que fait ce que fait mater ou cette
finance bac d'abord il faut rappeler de
la section à droite c'est pour ça c'est
pas ça du tout d'ailleurs mouvement 5
étoiles beaucoup plus complexe que cela
mais le sait la preuve sa confusion
entre autres les choses il y à il y à
une convention internationale sur les
réfugiés et qui est très peu respecté
par les pays européens y compris par la
france qui ne qui ne rentrent pas dans
les quotas imposés par par cette
convention est ce qui arrive vous avez
des réfugiés de guerre et où climatique
et vous avez des migrants économiques
c'est absurde pas la même chose et c'est
la vigne va traiter tout le monde l'a
dit que justement il respecterait des
dispositions et les cas vers des pays
qui doit pour le moment il donne ça il
dit au revoir à tout le monde et puis
j'aimerais bien voir comment il va se
débrouiller avec le pape
est ce que le papa a promis l'avait déjà
fait il avait accueilli des réfugiés
syriens en leur donnant le passeport un
passeport du vatican une douzaine mais
les premiers à l'époque de écoutez si si
personne ne respecte les droits humains
le vatican sur un point de passage pour
ça vous la vendre et ça vous l'a prouvé
que le vatican justement et j'approuve
que le pape fasse ce que fait les papes
c'est à dire le ca des consciences il
devrait faire ses conséquences oui mais
le fab s'occupe de questions pour une
fois humaine et et c'est aux politiques
de trouver des solutions aux
catastrophes qu'il crée et c'est encore
une fois on peut reparler la des graves
problèmes et des conséquences qu'ont les
les accords de libre échange
tant qu'on continuera à avoir des
accords de libre échange et des traités
libre-échange absurde qu'on impose au
niveau européen on aura recélant plus
marc landré justement vida nous dit sur
sur facebook
on a beau ne pas aimer le nouveau
gouvernement et non sans raison la
question de l'immigration est vital pour
l'italie pour le reste de l'ordre
oui surtout la question la question de
la migration laisser cette migration qui
vient de l'est de l'afrique du nord on a
eu on a quand même déjà plus de trente
mille personnes qui ont traversé la
méditerranée depuis le début de l'année
alors certes c'est trois fois moins qu'à
la même période l'année dernière mais
c'est quand même trente mille personnes
qui sont arrivées en italie en grèce et
à partir du moment où il ya une
défaillance de l'union européenne à
traiter à gérer ces flux migratoires
un pays est en droit de se défendre par
lui-même ou de prendre les mesures qui
s'imposent selon t-il enfin pense-t-il
vont pouvoir gérer son décès cette
immigration
je pense que n'importe quel peuple dans
le
dans le monde gérait confrontés au même
phénomène est serré d'apporter une
réponse peut-être pas la même réponse
en tout cas d'apporter soi même une
réponse quand il ya une défaillance dans
une zone économique commerciale une zone
politique qu'il a pour le coup ce monde
défaillante or andré j'entends ce que
disent que dix marques mais quand même
il y va un peu fort l'italien quand on
entend la en systèmes propose des camps
de rétention avec interdiction de sortir
n'y a pas de papier est allé tout ça
c'est la conséquence de quoi
c'est la conséquence que on a fait une
europe cul par dessus tête le mehdi vous
même si les politiques sont responsables
il faut sortir je vous dire il faut
faire un bruch site faut sortir
bruxelles de l'europe c'est le bruch
site qu'il faut faire on a fait l'europe
drôle mais si je peux parler je vous ai
dit c'est très simple on l'a fait
l'europe contre les peuples
on a fait l'europe sans penser au peuple
la question migrantes arrive et c'est le
retour du refoulé pendant des années et
des années et des années on n'a pas
voulu voir madame merkel a fait le
pyromane est aujourd'hui elle essaye
désespérément de faire le pompier c'est
à dire que le problème tout le monde et
pour l'asie vous disais tout mais tout
le monde est pour le moins bien sûr
c'est pas le problème le problème c'est
quand vous avez une immigration de masse
qui n'est pas du tout contrôler ça
arrive vous l'avais dit dans deux ou
trois pays qui subissent le bois mais le
reste que phil urbaine monsieur juncker
qu'est ce qui se passe pourquoi vraiment
l'élément dirimant l'élément dirigeants
drs en sélection italienne ça a été la
question migratoire le fait qu en
allemagne aujourd'hui angela merkel a
reculé de façon drastique
c'est pas l'économie c'est les migrants
le fait qu'il y a un problème
je ne parle pas de l'europe de l'est
regardez leur blesse qui est passé en
centrifugeuse
regardez la slovénie hier hier les
élections slovène pourquoi alors on peut
se dire oui ils sont pas bien alors
évidemment on position dans les peuples
et l'échangé c'est plus compliqué en
même temps il y a un problème migratoire
qu'on a laissé faire on a laissé faire
les passeurs on allait faire de celle
vers le trafic on a laissé nos cousins
sans du tout régulé et je vous dis
pourquoi pas l'acheter pas parce qu'il
fallait refoulés mais parce qu'il
fallait réguler et on l'a dit alors des
boues
et vous et c'est ça que je veux dire par
rapport pourquoi je dis brooks hic c'est
que cette union européenne s'est fait
uniquement sur des critères bureaucrates
et pas du tout en tenant compte des
peuples et on voit très bien que
l'europe en tant que mouvement populaire
fond moi je suis pour l'europe
je suis fondamentalement pour l'europe
mais pas cette europe là pas cette
europe dont seulement du libre-échange
c'était quoi le libre échange on a vu ce
que ça a donné libre circulation des
hommes des richesses etc
sauf qu'à un moment donné se passe cette
espèce de basculement migratoires
qu'est-ce qu'on fait rien mais qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire réguler
c'est réglé en dix ans et coûté au delà
de cette limite aux poteaux moi je suis
pas certaine qu'il fallait des quotas
par exemple mais je pense qu'il ya deux
aspects c'est soit on règle le problème
et le problème se règle au niveau
européen il faut l'accepter soit on fait
de la politique
effectivement on s'amuse à faire de la
politique chacun dans son pays en fait
c'est ça qui se passe en ce moment c'est
si c'était si c'est en a la capacité de
s'installer autour d'une table tous les
27 à essayer de voir ce qu'on peut
concrètement faire il est probable qu'on
arrive à trouver des règles qu'on arrive
à édicter des règles pour organiser les
flux migratoires non non attendez
charlie barr le problème les besoins des
paris attendait les quais romane je
reprends ce que andré bercoff disait sur
angela merkel je suis pas d'accord engel
à merkel face à l'afflux qui a eu on
avait tous vu ces images là accepte
effectivement que huit cent mille
migrants entre en allemagne ça a changé
prendre à temps ça a changé quoi dans le
pays
le taux de chômage aujourd'hui en
allemagne et combien 3,8 pour cent
est ce qu'ils ont perdu en pouvoir
d'achat les allemands ne s'est pas passé
culturel pardon vous oublié l'essentiel
c'est pas le taux de chômage s'est pas
l'économie c'est culturel je file au
second pack city qu'aujourd'hui c'est
lui qui doit effectivement donné
normalement le là c'est lui qui doit
construire la société qui va si vite il
va normalement essayer d'aiguillés
dedans mais le peuple vers quelque chose
et si il faut peut-être pas changer les
valeurs culturelles d'un pays mais en
tout cas essayer d'expliquer qu'il ya
des choses qui sont en train de se
passer et qu'il faut peut-être s'y
adapter voilà moi je trouve que angela
merkel a fait preuve d'une grande force
et aujourd'hui quand j'observe la
politique de manama
fond je trouve ça décevant que pendant
une campagne présidentielle soit capable
de dire ces merveilleuses café madame
merkel mais que pour ne pas se faire
déborder c'est juste de la politique de
la petite politique pour ne pas se
laisser déborder par l'extrême droite
finalement on a aujourd'hui un mini zoo
l'intérieur qu'un discours qui flirte
avec celui de marine le pen
coline meissonnier nous dit sur
lefigaro.fr il faut faire voter les
français sur la question par référendum
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais il
faudrait déjà avec la question les
questions migratoires sont extrêmement
compliquées
là on parle systématiquement et 16 me
parle du du sommet de l'iceberg
on oublie totalement et très étonnamment
l'extrême droite ou si la la les
migrations intra européennes qui sont
colossales
à côté les 30000 personnes qui
traversent la méditerranée c'est ici
rien de l'italie 2 millions de personnes
sont de jeunes sont partis ils partent
parce qu'à cause des politiques
d'austérité parce qu'il n'ya pas que le
problème des déplacements population il
ya des politiques d'austérité qui eux
aussi font voter pour pour
l'extrême-droite et ont amené et ont été
un sujet important dans l'élection en
italie mais depuis septembre 2010 est la
signature du traité de libre échange
entre l'union européenne et l'ukraine
un million de jeunes ukrainiens qui sont
partis quelque part vers la pologne
notamment au gras pologne la pologne il
ya une gamme bien conflit sur les
migrants mais pas les migrants qui
viennent d'afrique c'est le milan qui
viennent de crem juste à côté et vous
avez les ouvriers polonais qui partent
en europe et tout ça est illégal parce
qu'on est tous européens on peut
s'installer où on veut et puis vous avez
les systèmes de travailleurs détachés
qui permettent l'exploitation de toute
cette misère et parle pas oui mais si
ces mêmes sujets parce que c'est
c'est le problème c'est que beaucoup de
ceux qui traversent
non mais attendez qu'ils sont colorés je
suis une question qui sont colorés de
haut
souvent on viennent de zones de conflit
en particulier côtier la crise
migratoire ou donc dont on parle kiwi et
qui venaient de syrie que les grandes
masses des séries le problème alors que
cela soit non mais pardon du
moyen-orient d'afrique et d'afrique
quand on vient du sud du nigeria par
exemple c'est pas des pays en conflit
pourtant riche d'afrique
il ya une zone de conflit mais on a mis
sur pied la mise et s'il ya une
migration économique
on le sait très bien il n'y a pas que
migration pays en guerre s'il n'y aurait
pas un tel pourcentage d'hommes et de
jeunes hommes qui seraient là est le
problème il n'est pas là le problème
encore une fois il est culturel vous
parliez angela merkel a fait un bond
mais qu'est-ce qui a joué chez les
allemands c'est le 31 décembre 2015 à
cologne il ya eu mille viol il ya eu
mille violent pourquoi parce qu'il y
avait chaque culture elle alors pour en
discuter on peut trouver ça on peut
s'adapter
il ya des gens qui n'ont pas envie de
s'adapter et il y a eu des véritables et
quand je dis mais il n'y a pas une
cologne il ya eu dans toute l'europe des
problèmes alors je ne dis pas du tout ce
qui serait totalement lamentable veut
dire que la majorité d'immigrants que
mais il y à ce problème là et
franchement comme on n'a pas voulu en
parler et je vais vous dire deux choses
plus sur des véritables passions nos
valeurs dont 15 me 15 mille jeunes
filles de 11 à 16 ans à telford et à
rotterdam en angleterre pendant dix ans
ont été tabassés exploiter prostituées
ou sont les féministes par des gangs de
pakistanais
pardon ça on la préfère qui s'est passé
on a su il y avait les assistantes
sociales tout ça on n'en parle pas sinon
ça fait ça fait du racisme
donc on a quand même tous cette espèce
de non dits et de peur en vison la tap -
j'attaque je skie ordures et bertoua
blanc noir des violences qui sont commis
par des conférences pas au niveau de
dell dame et de redford
regardez ce qui s'est passé c'est dans
les tous les journaux anglais la presse
française dans la pratiquement pas parlé
du lien avec les grands d'afrique du
nord je vois pas le lien mais par sur le
jeu et culturelle je répète quand vous
avez en couleur et ce qui s'est passé il
y a un lien culturel et les gens se
sentent jamais ce qu'on se donne pas les
moyens de vous pour les intégrer de vous
rend les assimiler j'y raconte ya eu les
vagues d'immigration d'europe de l'est
dans les années 30 ou même d'italie
on les a intégrés s'est intégré on
appris jeudi
l'europe migrants dont ckoi à lorient la
voix mais qu'est ce qu'on fait après
quelques saisons au début
bon c'est comme si on voyait là on
attend que les gens s'en aillent et
coface et qu'on fasse rien et qu'on
attende que ça se passe voilà un dernier
point un dernier point que je voulais
soumettre justement votre plateau c'est
l'interview de pierre vermeren ce matin
dans le figaro est à retrouver dans le
figaro.fr qui dit l'immigration massive
venant d'afrique est présenté comme
unique table d'un phénomène naturel ou
climatique
or les chinois pauvreté plus d'un
milliard mais n'ont jamais débarquer au
japon la faire et donc politique
et d'ajouter je cite encore les états du
style sud peuvent stopper du jour au
lendemain des flux migratoires
georges et kuzmanovic qu'est ce que vous
en pensez quand vous entendez ça depuis
mes cours de 6ème en mathématiques je ne
mélange pas les pommes de terre les
carottes et je sais pas de quoi ils
parlent
je n'ai aucun rapport les deux
situations et puis à une époque les
chiens ont cessé d'envahir le japon et
il a été sauvé par les camille et des
centaines de milliers de soldats sont
morts depuis de plusieurs siècles japon
ans raconte ce sera contre 7 les gens ce
que dit ker lann également puisque en
dehors de situer le contexte il dit il
ya parfois le maroc l'aller la libye de
kadhafi et la tunisie ont impliqué des
mesures drastiques au début notamment
aux et début des années 2000 au maroc
qui ont stoppé qui ont stoppé l'immigré
alors je vais reprendre que ce que j'ai
pas le temps de finir tout à l'heure
effectivement kadhafi avait des
nombreuses à queue avec des accords avec
avec l'europe est bloqué lequel migrants
mais aussi la société libyenne avait un
niveau de standards de vie quatre fois
supérieur à l'egypte voisine
or on a totalement désintégré ce pays
ainsi que d'autres par des guerres une
guerre directe absolument inutile créer
des conditions pour avoir des gens qui
perdent leur niveau de vie et qui mirent
et ça visiblement on le on ne le prend
pas en compte et si on prend pas en
compte on peut pas trouver de solution
de la même manière on ne
il sort des conséquences lourdes si on
ne change pas cette politique absurde de
vouloir faire des traités de libre
échange avec dp avec des économies qui
n'ont pas le même niveau
je rappelle que la colonisation au début
de la colonisation l'objectif c'était
d'avoir de nouveaux marchés pour la
production pour la production
industrielle française anglaise
allemande et les zapper les accords de
partenariat économique c'est strictement
la même chose c'est ouvrir des marchés
qui n'ont aucune chance de résister à
nos industriels
agriculture au déversement de nos
produits pour qu'ils les achètent vous
produisez là-bas des pauvres de la
misère et les migrantes et mais d'abord
la mort parce que voilà les migrants les
migrations intra africaines si on ne
l'est plus le lien de cause à effet
entre le libre échange et les problèmes
migratoires ont ce qu'on s'apprête à
vivre une migration qui va être dix fois
quinze fois supérieur à cause des
problèmes climatiques le libre échange
n'a strictement n'aura strictement rien
à voir avec cette vague d'immigration
qu'on va connaître et à laquelle on
n'est pas préparé et on n'est pas au
pire ça sera pire comme et aux relations
ni n'est pas automatique
non mon vahiné déjà en cachant pas mon
vrai problème maintenant sur le
problématique qui vient après je moi je
pense que la fin une partie du problème
effectivement comme disait karine c'est
cette incapacité de l'europe à se mettre
autour d'une table pour trouver une
solution à cette chose qu'elle de fait
ils arrivent les migrants ils sont là
donc on ne voit pas les met dans un
bateau est noyé il coulait donc il faut
dire sans occuper faut bien faire
quelque chose donc et on voit
effectivement comme vous le disiez
vincent avec l'accord qui dit à deux ans
on était incapable de le mettre en
oeuvre
et quand on l'a fait voter avec eux en
mettant les pays de l'est en minorité
ils ont pas être ils ont ils ont refusé
les des quotas entre guillemets qui leur
avait été un chiffre astronomique jir
que j'ai relevé la slovaquie devait
accueillir 900 de migrants ils ont
accueilli 16 16
la république tchèque 2691 ayant
accueilli une nouvelle façon qu'ils
avaient trouvé en fait d'accepter
l'accord tout en ne l'appliquant pas
parce que sinon ils étaient pas sous le
coup des sanctions comme elles sont ce
serait la porte ouverte depuis deux ans
et c'est parce qu'elles ont perdu dans
les limbes mais ça c'est une force ce
sont des pays d'émigration que la
plupart des pays de l'asean et pays
sondés sont des pays d'où les jeunes par
arte
aucun sens je dois aller travailler dans
un pays où les changements donnent la
parole je voudrais qu'on la donne aux
internautes du figaro
et donc qu'ils peuvent toujours voté
soutenez-vous la proposition d'angela
merkel de créer une agence européenne de
l'immigration pour l'instant le oui l
emporte tout petit peu 51 % arnaud dudit
jeu comprend et soutient totalement la
position de salvini fabrice nous dit
revoir le traité de dublin au sein de
l'union européenne
de plus l'europe doit aider
véritablement les pays africains à
affronter le phénomène arnaud nous dit
encore le ras-le-bol qui monte en europe
est d'abord une question sociétale et
non économique et nous avons également
le drapier qui dit pourquoi personne ne
se réfère à la définition juridique des
réfugiés je reviens moi quand même sur
nos politiques
notre classe politique qui est incapable
en fait d'avoir une parole forte
aujourd'hui elle se cachait
systématiquement derrière son opinion
publique
son opinion publique aujourd'hui elle
habite par exemple le coeur de ville de
dijon
à dijon on voit pas des migrants comme
ça quoi et pourtant ces gens là une
partie importante crie au loup en disant
oh mon dieu non mais moi je veux surtout
pas qu'ils aient des migrants qui
arrivent chez moi est-ce que c'est pas
comme dit l'adage
le problème de l'insécurité culturelle
et non mais les gens on voit là les gens
ont peur ont ce sentiment d'insécurité
énorme
il voit dans les médias en permanence
des masses de gens comme ça arriver aux
frontières ils sont persuadés que demain
c'est dans leur ville que ça va arriver
et donc cette peur d'un autre côté
certains disent les médias ne nous
disent pas toute la vérité sur les
migrations
non mais peut-être bien suivre je dire
les métiers aujourd'hui sont pour rien
donc voilà on tort sur tout ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que je trouve ça
juste extrêmement dangereux quand même
qu'une classe politique aujourd'hui ne
sache plus que se cacher derrière son
opinion publique
surtout quand il me semble qu'elle ait
tort on y reviendra sur assure un autre
des thèmes d'ailleurs qui sont sur le
qui sont au programme ce soir je
voudrais que on peut continuer à parler
sur les sur l'immigration on reviendra
en chose à dire quand même le dernier
mot le dernier mot simplement tant que
l'europe ne retrouvera pas le sentiment
national l'europe des nations et non pas
l'europe de bruxelles
rien ne sera changé ce qui se passe en
europe de l'est est ce le rôle de
l'essor avec andré bercoff et bien vous
pouvez continuez à nous le dire car nbk
elle annoncé
donc le peuple avait à voter c'est ce
que nous dit j [ __ ] d'un voyant voir leurs
solutions on continuera et bien
justement de les examiner
on va s'intéresser à un autre qui est
une autre question qui dans l'actualité
240 voix pour 85 contre le sénat adopte
sans surprise la réforme de la sncf
alors question les syndicats doivent
t'ils jeter l'épongé
et puis tout pour ou contre la poursuite
de la grève à la sncf
ça c'est la question qu'on pose sur
twitter en attendant voici la réponse à
toutes ces questions de philippe
martinez on écoute le patron de la cgt
si j'étais elle va continuer comme l a
annoncé le mouvement en cours jusque fin
juin ce qui est la date prévue pour
l'instant
ce que je constate c'est que la
mobilisation a permis des reculs du
gouvernement
voyez la dette c'était pas prévu de la
reprendre
elle est pour une part reprises mais il
reste à discuter un certain nombre de
choses on parle beaucoup de la
convention collective qui n'existe
toujours pas c'est à dire que pour
l'instant les cheminots ont le choix
entre leur statut ou rien du tout et
vous comprenez que ça inquiète du monde
ya besoin de maintenir la pression et de
maintenir ce débat sur de quoi nous
avons besoin dans notre pays en matière
de mobilité sordia karine le
gouvernement a gagné
je n'ai pas envie de présenter les
choses comme ça mais en revanche c'est
une question n'attendez pas non je suis
pas certaine qu'on puisse dire les
choses comme ça maintenant c'est vrai
que le gouvernement a su tactiquement
assez bien joué et est notamment
je rappelle par exemple sur il parlait
philippe martinez de la reprise de la
dette initialement quand même souvenons
nous que le premier ministre dit la
dette on en parlera quand la réforme
quand l'entreprise acceptera de se
réformer
j'ai pas exactement compris que
l'entreprise va totalement se réformer
mais très vite en fait il ya plus d'une
dizaine de jours maintenant je crois
edouard philippe annonce effectivement
qui vont reprendre 35 milliards je ne
trompe pas 35 milliard en deux temps
donc finalement très vite il a dit je
fais un énorme geste vers vous c'est
compliqué pour les fameux syndicats dits
réformistes de dire on n'a rien entendu
et on continue à se battre de la même
façon et puis il ya un certain nombre
d'amendements au sénat qui ont été
totalement dictée par ces mêmes
syndicats réformistes
à partir de là à partir du moment où
vous créez une faille dans l'union
syndicale tenir devient extrêmement
compliqué donc le gouvernement n'a pas
encore complètement gagné parce qu'on
sent bien que philippe martinez
notamment n'a pas envie de lâcher
mais il a le calendrier parlementaire
complètement contre lui je vois pas
comment la réforme aujourd'hui ne va pas
passer à la commission mixte paritaire
qu'a lieu le 11 juin
cette réforme sera adoptée par le
parlement donc à partir de là c'est fini
alors philippe arthonnaise nous dit
qu'il va jouer le coup jusqu'au 28 juin
oui enfin c'est un baroud d'honneur ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui était attendue
et prévisible
le gouvernement avance à son rythme
selon son calendrier on a en avançant
ses pièces les unes après les autres la
dette effectivement je suis d'accord
karine le premier ministre au départ
l'avait un peu éludé
mais plus pour des raisons politiques
vis-à-vis de bruxelles que pour des
raisons internes vis-à-vis des syndicats
tout le monde s'investit comme m oui
mais enfin c'était surtout par rapport à
bruxelles parce que plus tôt il disait
je reprends la dhr est plutôt c'était
compliqué parce qu'on n'était pas encore
sorti de la procédure de déficit
excessif vis-à-vis de la commission
européenne donc c'était tactique
politique vis-à-vis de votre selle et
syndicales savez les discussions ont
commencé très tôt avec les syndicats
réformistes qui sont entrés dans la
danse dans la balle dans le dans le jeu
pour pouvoir discuter du fameux sac à
dos sociale pour pouvoir parler des
modalités lors de sakado social c'est
très joli
c'est très joli c'est une belle occasion
c'est un plaisir de la réunion de
rédaction de ce que vous avez il va y
avoir une ouverture à la concurrence
alors très peu de lignes pour est
ouverte à la concurrence à partir de
2020 il faut savoir que si tu une ligne
va être exploité demain par un
concurrent privé ou par un concurrent
public mais qui n'est pas la sncf
les salariés seront transférés les
salaires et les cncf les cheminots
seront transférées à ce nouvel opérateur
alors le avec le même statut le chèque
cadeau social c'est justement avec quoi
il va danser ce nouvel opérateur
donc c'est avec la garantie de l'emploi
là la garantie de sa rémunération le
maintien des conditions de départ en
retraite
ces sacs à dos et avec quoi le cheminot
va dans l'entreprise la nouvelle
entreprise pour exploiter la même ligne
ce qui va être différent c'est pas le
statut parce que le 7 8 le garde on va y
aura une modification des recrutements
non sous statut mais sous contrat privé
pour les nouveaux entrants pas pour les
anciens pour ceux qui sont actuellement
il vient leur statut et qu'est ce qui va
changer pour eux le jour où sur la base
du volontariat parce que c'est un des
acquis des discussions avec les
syndicats sur la base du volontariat
avec une garantie de retour dans
l'entreprise et lycées la sncf
si ça se passe mal qu'est ce qui se
passe pour eux on a été c'est qu'ils
vont travailler différemment ils vont
avoir les mêmes le même statut mais
qu'on y travaille différemment
pourquoi changer
elles vont être alors pour les semis au
havre être moins bonne mais c'est aussi
ce qui faisait qu aujourd'hui la sncf
avait 2,4 milliards de dettes quatre
maires de déficit par an le problème
c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ya des études
comparatives ont été faites entre la
manière dont fonctionne la sncf je peux
pas vous laisser dire ça c'est pas le
statut des cheminots qui fait que dans
un sens et l'asie les statuts facebook 1
6 milliard par exemple l'audition de
travail les conditions travail il faut
savoir prendre 15 kilos il est c'est
dans son contrat de travail
il fait une tâche vous êtes dans une
gare vous êtes cheminots vous êtes
préposé à changer les ampoules un autre
cheminot ne peut pas changer le vent
poupe parce que c'est pas dans sa
définition de poste
mais vous avez raison ça c'est vrai
esquisse alors que dans les autres les
autres organisations
c'est pas le cas sauf qu'on a besoin de
beaucoup moins de monde pour faire
fonctionner les mêmes entreprises
ailleurs il faut savoir que à la sncf il
faut 2,2 finaux là ou ailleurs il en
faut un rapport de 1 pour 2,2 donc ce
qui va changer pour les cheminots qui
seront transférées c'est simplement
qu'ils vont pas travailler dans les
mêmes conditions par exemple un
conducteur de train il ira dans le
hangar chercher le train il le sortira
et après le conduira là où aujourd'hui
il en faut 2 la différence allait la fin
le calcul que le gouvernement était de
dire le statut des cheminots coûté à
l'entreprise 400 millions d'euros par an
au départ 407 finalement tactique de
leur part il aurait pas dû parce que
c'est ce qui a braqué les syndicats à
raison pour après revenir en arrière et
dire le statut n'est pas les pas qui
dépasse qui empêche de tourner en rond
la sncf il faut réformer l'organisation
il faut réformer quand même deux choses
et investir dans les lignes ferroviaires
george est quand même est ce que comme
en disant 1068 il faut savoir finir une
plaisante 838 et en plus il ne faisait
pas qu'il y ait pas que ça disait il
faut savoir finir une grève quand on a
obtenu satisfaction et quand on a noté
une satisfaction il peut y avoir des
compromis qui fait qu' il faut qu'on
accepte de ne pas avoir tout gagné on
serait mal d'avoir marqué pour faire
cette précision est encore en cours
marxiste on comprend pourquoi il est
rédacteur en chef du site pour connaître
les propos de thorez effectivement on
finit nous ont fini de grève quand quand
on a gagné
papa quand pas quand elle est en cours
de tournée en cours de combat et je vous
félicite également pour l'explication
mais franchement c'est incompréhensible
le statut qui va passer d'une entreprise
à l'autre avec les lignes qui vont être
privatisées par privatiser c'est déjà
été fermé en bretagne sinon mais sinon
ça n'a rien à voir je vous ai pas fait
n'a rien n'a vraiment rien à voir ce que
voulait il en exemple ce que vous dites
est faux il n'y a pas eu d link
privatiser ci avec un des morceaux de
l'état avec dès maintenant en grande
bretagne on a eu lieu au privé le réseau
le réseau reste public en france donc ça
n'a rien à voir
est-ce qu'on allait privatiser le
transport de toutes les lignes ce qui
n'est pas le cas en france verra combien
de temps sur le public parce qu'à chaque
fois c'est fait par petits bouts et la
prochaine fois ça sera le réseau qui
sera privatisée en tout cas le chaos
était total dans ce prix au point où
l'état a dû refinancer en fait j'espère
que l'aller les cheminots ne prendront
pas parce que le problème ici n'est
encore une fois ce n'est pas juste sauvé
le statut des cheminots
c'est quand même l'argumentaire du
gouvernement c'est sauver le service
public parce que ce n'est pas que dans
les transports ferroviaires
ça va être dans dans les écoles ça va
être dans les hôpitaux mais quand une
loi est votée par le parlement fait
comment pour continuer
effectivement le gouvernement a décidé
de n'imposer un programme
il n'est pas ultra ultra ultra libérale
il le passe est mal passé le 11 juin
cela n'empêche pas de proposer de
continuer à lutter et de faire grève
enfin pourquoi ce qu'il faudrait qu'on
accepte c'est ce que vous dites
légitimité quand légitimité d'agir ils
appliquent la même politique il
appliquer quand il était secrétaire
quand il était coursier de monsieur
domine c'est un politique qui vous votez
pour lui qui a été élu par une
abstention de 56% au second tour et donc
par à peine un quart des français et il
est il et il est légalement élu la
légitimité c'est un petit peu autre
chose il me semble en politique ces
blocs a raison encore une fois ceux ci
doivent être des gens au chômage va
rendre compliqué les transports en
france et ceci nous vient non pas de
maquereaux et livre le pauvre ont mené
un combat n'est pas coupable dans ce
domaine ça nous vient du pacte
ferroviaire qui étaient décidées à 15
ans à bruxelles au lieu de faire un
système ferroviaire auquel tous les
européens pourraient s'attacher qu'ils
soient européens avec un service public
européen
ils vont mettre la guerre des mines ne
se sont pas disons que c'est la
politique monsieur ils vont mettre en
l'air politiques tous les os mais non
ils vont mettre en guerre les services
les chemins de fer les uns contre les
autres et provoquer encore plus de
détestation de cette europe là alors le
jeu donne la parole aux camarades
bercoff alors que je jouais quand vous
entendez que le pourfendeur de 35 heures
quand même que vous avez été des râles
donc pas libérable le pourfendeur
populaire les 35 heures est bien obligé
de dire 'voilà d'akron dans cette fois
mais attendez bravo macron macro
pratique toujours le côté fringues genre
dont il est là dont il à la plage ça
veut dire qu'il ne va pas c'est en fait
bon jeu pour résumer sur la sncf le le
le les syndicats ont perdu la jeune
elisa il a gagné est vraiment en quoi il
a gagné il a gagné et là au maquereau
fait violence j'adore lycées pas chef de
l'état qui paye c'est à dire on rampe
renfloue fait la dette
le contribuable payera tout va bien bon
le vrai problème c'est que moi je suis
effectivement pour qu'il y est
un statut le premier problème qu'est-ce
qui rentrent mais c'est un problème de
fond dont on n'a pas du tout discuté et
même qu'est ce qui rend dans le service
public qu'est ce qui doit être dans un
pays aujourd'hui au 21ème siècle quel
sur les domaines qui doivent rester
demeurer dans le service public
moi j'ai l'impression qu'on joue avec ça
et qu'on ne va pas jusqu'au bout des
choses est ce que le train la sncf les
transports peut-être oui alors à ce
moment là on fait des moyens ce que vous
disiez changé on prend les moyens on dit
c'est un service public on prend les
moyens de le faire et on reste c'est
dans on montre à la concurrence
ce que j'aime pas chez macromedia pas
que macro à gauche comme à droite etc
c'est ce flou artistique comment la peur
de heurter qu'on dise on dise écouter
non c'est destine à être privatisées à
jour on va y arriver et c'est non pour
des raisons électorales ce jour rien
juste juste un point précis vous
compariez tout à l'heure la réforme
ferroviaire française à la grande
bretagne le plus juste la puce
comparaison c'est avec l'allemagne c'est
pas la grande bretagne quand même jour
et arnaud nous dit la grande bretagne
est en train de re nationaliser une
partie de son rail pourquoi à bruxelles
d'ailleurs on se demande pas pour les
mines on a pas on va patrie baptisé le
rail hier c'est vraiment voir un jour
non bah oui mais peut-être dont 200 en
maintenant la comparaison avec
l'allemagne l'allemagne
ils ont ouvert la concurrence un certain
nombre de lignes savez-vous aujourd'hui
en allemagne
quel pourcentage des lignes sont en
concurrence non mais des 30% 70% reste
de l' apanage de la sociaux de la
deutsche bahn de la société nationale
donc il n'y a pas eu de privatisation du
réseau est simplement une ouverture la
concurrence de quelques lignes qui sont
les lignes effectivement rentable ça
marche et ça m'a oui ça marche ça marche
très bien
ça marche très bien vous vous entendez
pas de problème sur donc ça sert à rien
de crier au catastrophisme en disant oh
là là oh là là là là on va voir ce qu'on
va voir maintenant qu'on va ouvrir un
petit peu la concurrence le rail
français par exemple prenez de total de
lignes qui ont fermé pour beaucoup de
citoyens
c'est un problème qui a été dit ou
montré besoin d'être derrière dijon tout
à l'heure autour de 10
là les connexions autour de la grande
communauté de dijon sont très
problématiques les gens n'arrivent
son but est de prendre la voiture de
faire des horaires et sans dédaigner
l'autocar mais adam savage deux jours ou
plus mal joué on a jusqu'au 28 juin
transporter les gens le travail à la
maison sans qu'ils en phase 3 on espère
en avoir que jusqu'au 28 juin ça s'est
excusé moi c'est mon opinion personnelle
mais c'est mieux de mu âgées des trains
de banlieue et un savoir faire
concernant ce que vous payez japonais en
plus c'est finalement je suis client et
j'ai pas été encore remboursé d'ailleurs
on nous avait promis d'être remboursé ça
qu'on est forcé à 50 des mois précédents
je n'ai toujours pas été donc j'attends
de voir
quand est ce que ce sera un soleil à
cette promesse ou bien s'il s'agit d'une
chose auquel je me s'était engagé que
parce que j'y croyais on va juste
prendre les remarques des internautes
arnaud donc nous demander à roko le
statut du cheminot serait vital pro
service public comme nous le vendre la
cgt il faut que les cheminots soit
polyvalent nous dit pat cette réforme
est juste et nécessaire et des syndicats
ont perdu ils ont l'opinion publique
contre eux vous faut pas charrier ne dit
faut pas charrier s'est pas complètement
vrai parce que pour la défense du
service public les l'opinion publique
est plutôt favorable à la défendre et
notamment sur les histoires des lignes
secondaires
financièrement nous dit valentin la
réforme qui n'est pas dans la réforme
financièrement la sncf s'en sortira
comment de cette grève
rapidement marque voilà c'est à peu près
400 millions de pertes 400 millions
d'euros de pertes et bien une autre
question de perte qu'elle perd tu peux
provoqué l'opération qui est en cours
contre les produits israéliens voici ce
qu'on peut voir dans une dans un
supermarché de martigues
c'était le trot le 3 juin dernier
voilà dans les mains de cet homme
on voit un produit fabriqué en israël
alors on savait que des associations
appelé à boycotter les produits
israéliens là maintenant il ya des
actions commando pour étirer ses
produits ou dénoncés en plein
supermarché andré bercoff qu'est ce que
ça vous inspire
ou deux honnêtement rien de bon parce
que je pense que quand on entre on
commence à emprunter cette voie
on va aller très loin c'est à dire que à
partir du moment où un pays à tord ou à
raison est considéré comme je dirais
nécessitera effectué brico de ses
produits
très sincèrement si on fait la liste des
pays qui ont besoin qu'on les sanctionne
y en a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup qui
devrait passer avant israël est bien
avant par rapport au traitement qu'ils
font un certain nombre de choses
deuxièmement il y avait loué en plein
pendant ces implantations de votre cas
ça serait terrible pour générer plus de
votre canon les supermarchés non mais
oui bah voilà aussi aimé parlons pas
vers cette voie là ne parlons pas
descendre et c'est là ce que je trouve
moi extrêmement déplorable dans cette
histoire c'est la focalisation la
focalisation uniquement sur israël j'ai
remarqué une chose c'est que ce qui se
passe au yémen ce qui se passe en libye
par rapport à l' esclavage des noirs par
les libyens parce qu'on sait
qu'aujourd'hui on m'a traîné au soudan
il a de véritables stages est revenu ce
n'était jamais des réponses étaient en
attente et alors on dit a pas de
produits mauritaniens ou libyens etc
enfin je veux dire il y à une loi la loi
doit être appliquée c'est à partir de
quel moment je veux dire l'on dit ou est
elle en osier mais moi demain je vais
faire un petit commando
je vais m'en prendre à tel ou tel ou tel
ou tel pays je crois que c'est en plus
ce qui a quelque chose il ya un saut
qualitatif
avant c'était les produits qui étaient
uniquement dans les territoires occupés
maintenant c'est les produits israéliens
alors ça c'est quand même beaucoup plus
grave ça veut dire quoi que tout israël
est un territoire occupé alors faisons
comme le hamas et allons-y
moi ça me gêne marou coup même si jusque
sa marque c'est un impact économique sur
nos relations
non non c
avez vous avez trois groupuscules qui
décide de faire des opérations sur les
réseaux sociaux
une opération qui rebondissent et sur
les quelques communiqués socio
économiquement sanasa des happenings
justement c'est tout le sens d'ailleurs
tout ce que révèle stéphane kovacs matin
mais dans le figaro l'article est
également retrouvée sur le figaro.fr
prenez prenez pas trop d'où il prenait
prenez de rappeler les boycotts contre
des marques comme danone courrier lu au
début des années 2000 on se rend compte
et c'était autre chose que des
groupuscules à tort ou à raison qui
débarque dans quelques supermarchés pour
retirer des produits
c'est scandaleux c'est inadmissible
c'est vrai mais l'impact économique
puisque c'est là qu'ils ont composée pro
d2 la donne dans les rues d'ibiza les
2000 qu'est ce qui s'est passé oui il ya
eu un impact sur l'avant les ventes de
produits au début mais au final au bout
d'un moment ça revient à la normale ça
repart comme avant
je veux dire c'est donc économiquement
ça n'a pas de poids ce sont des coups
médiatiques sont des coûts de
communication des coûts de groupuscules
je parle de communauté dans ce cas là
moi je vais appeler à un boycott si je
n'aime pas la politique que font les
italiens contre les migrants je dis
arrêtons d'acheter des pâtes italiennes
ou de la morena d'elle dans les
supermarchés georget il ya des militants
de la france sera soumise qui ont fait
retirer des pamplemousses et des avocats
vous approuvez ce genre de civilisation
nous avions voté 2 en trois ans déjà
pour le programme bds donc de boycott je
rappelle que la faisait une comparaison
entre des états et des citoyens sur des
activités de citoyens on peut pas je
sais que macro à gagner qu'il a raison
et qu'il a postaux au rouleau
compresseur mais ce sont des activités
de citoyens on peut être d'accord ou pas
d'accord mais ce sont des sons des
associations qui lance un combat
politique et donc il essaie de le
médiatiser secours juste deux minutes
puisque vous parlez de la campagne bds
et je vous redonne à part le juste après
mais justement l'ambassadrice d'israël
en france en a parlé mais ds c'est
boycott désinvestissement sanctions qui
est une campagne internationale qui
appelle au boycott des produits
israéliens et voici ce qu'en disait ce
matin un visa bino sur europe 1 ça n'est
pas la première fois que ça arrive et ça
montre encore une fois dé quoi il s'agit
et
lorsque l'on parle de bds parce qu'il
s'agit des organisations bds qui sont
soutenus par des éléments et musulmans
c'est à dire que c'est un sort de cette
ces organisations et ils ne veulent pas
reconnaître là le droit d'israël
d'exister dans nos régions il s'agit
exactement de cela et ça il faut
comprendre très bien je suis pas
musulman et puis je reconnais à
l'existant il y en a il vient de dire ce
sont tous des organisations derrière la
callas des musulmans et des gens qui
sont contre l'existence d'israël je veux
en porte à faux à 100% pour la france
insoumise pour le parti de gauche
nous sommes pour l'existence de l'état
d'israël et qui la droite se défendent
comme tous les états ce n'a absolument
rien à voir un certain john kerry qui me
semble pas être un extrémiste
bolchévique mais un l'ancien ministre
des affaires étrangères mais états unis
a qualifié israël d' état d'apartheid
on a déjà fait des sanctions d'état
contre l'afrique du sud
là ce sont des citoyens qui mène une
action pour montrer ce qui ne va pas
j'en ai bientôt les israéliens mais une
autre est de recourir à la brutalité
d'intimidation quelle brutalité une
fille fait une activité banque en
montrant à pamplemousses oued en france
certains cas il s'est dit oui mais faut
et s'il vous plaît il faut comparer ce
qui est comparable depuis moins de mars
netanyahu une énième fois s'assied sur
le droit international ne respecte pas
depuis 1967 les les les
les décisions de l'onu il a une centaine
de morts depuis mois de mars plusieurs
milliers de blessés ou sciences vous
comparez les violences avec quelqu'un
qui enlève réponses ne seront donc déçus
mais cette personne peut être poursuivie
par le supermarché
il s'expliquera en tant que militants
devant un juge ça n'empêche pas en tant
que citoyens de s'engager pour ce sur
quoi les novateurs et je suis juste
précisé que après cette émission et
j'irai avec le reste de france à sont
mises du parti de gauche fait faire une
manifestation aux invalides contre la
venue netanyahu qui va strictement
servir une seule chose c'est
l'alignement de macron à la politique
américaine et israélienne face à l'iran
et chercher les autorisations de bronac
nation vous avez pas piqué des quinze
jours non mais ça fait partie de ceux de
ce combat là
ce qui m'étonne vraiment parce que vous
êtes là effectivement dans quelque chose
ou services français très populaire en
tout cas d'une certaine partie de la
population des lits sur l unique objet
de notre ressentiment mais pas une image
res avoir l'heure juste moi j'ai surtout
c'est vraiment danser soumises ou permet
brille quand les syriens ont bombardé le
camp de yarmouk le camp palestinien de
yarmouk
il ya eu trois mille huit cents morts je
n'ai pas aujourd'hui un mot de la france
azou mise sur le bombardement du camp
palestinien de yarmouk et ça que je
reproche on importe quoi eh ben c'est la
semaine dernière la semaine dernière
monsieur ça les andes sur un joli très
variable ça va pas quand on les insoumis
on est évident mais on est à dix n'y est
absolument partout mais là s'il vous
plaît alors on parlait justement dit
sereine sur le vous parlez de yarmouk et
le condamné est maintenant sur la
survenue sur le cheval est resté on va
rester sur les rails et karine bcm n'a
par exemple pas parler français
à ces absences mais je pense que enfin
alors sauf la france a soumis ses
commandos parle de boycott mais
rappelons quand même
ce que ça signifie boycott je dire
boycott veut pas dire interdire
moi ce qui me dérange en fait dans cette
opération là c'est ça quand on boycotte
quand on appelle au boycott des
élections par exemple on dit pas
interdiction d'aller voter vous décider
en conscience
si effectivement vous pensez qu'il est
bon de respecter la pensée de ces gens
qui se défendent et je trouve que là
c'est c'est totalement perverti le
boycott pourquoi pas il peut exister sur
des produits israéliens ça peut faire
réagir certaines personnes mais qu'on
laisse en conscience les gens regarder
le produit qu'ils achètent et s'ils ont
envie de continuer à acheter ses
produits israéliens ou pas mais je suis
contre ces commandos c'est illégal et
c'est du communautarisme c'est ce que
lui d'une battre ces actions sont une
honte dit anti petit depuis 1977 rageux
ne faut pas charrier une loi en france
interdit le boycott
olivier face à ces groupuscules
anti-israël que peuvent faire les
magasins
vous avez la réponse d'ailleurs dans
l'article de stéphane kovacs que vous
retrouvez dans le figaro sur lefigaro.fr
il suffit simplement de regarder les
étiquettes indiquant la provenance
répond microlax et antoine dit je dis
non au boycott
il est anti démocratique autre polémique
la visite annoncée les manades macron à
rochefort en charente-maritime dans la
maison véhicules l'écrivain pierre loti
c'est le 14 juin prochain
en cause des écrits objectivement
scandaleuse sur les juifs et sur les
arméniens de cet écrivain qui a pourtant
écrit le mythique pêcheurs d'islande
dans le monde vendredi dernier l'uejf
sos racisme et le conseil représentatif
des arméniens de france demandent le
retrait de la maison de pierre loti de
la liste des 18 sites sélectionnés pour
le loto du patrimoine et même qu'on
débaptise les établissements scolaires
qui porte le nom de pierre loti
alors avant d'avoir votre avis en
demande celui des internautes sur
twitter est ce qu'il faut continuer à
sauver la maison de pierre loti vous
votez sur twitter est pour l'instant la
maison de pierre loti temps pendant
doivent être exclues du loto du
patrimoine c'est plutôt ça la question
est pour l'instant vous êtes une
écrasante majorité à répondre non avant
d'avoir votre avis on écoute celui de
stéphane bern le responsable de la
mission patrimoine d'abord je
des monuments je vais pas à sauver la
mémoire de tel ou tel
on sauve des monuments ensuite ne
mettons pas notre regard d'aujourd'hui
sur sur des personnages qui ont vécu au
19e siècle
je pense par exemple à jules ferry les
nomme jules ferry et et colonialiste et
l'a écrit il faut donc des baptisés tous
les tous les lycées jules ferry de
france j'ai écouté là pour une fois je
serais d'accord avec stéphane bern ça
veut dire qu'il faudrait qu'on dynamite
il faudrait dynamiter la sainte chapelle
ou titre que ça lui a mis des chapeaux
jaunes et à déporter les jeux de france
est ce qu'il a fait et ce qui est
inacceptable
mais cela on peut quand même se demander
pourquoi est-ce-que macron choisi cette
maison alors qu'effectivement pierre
loti a eu des textes particulièrement
violents contre les juifs et contre les
arméniens mais non en fait c'est l'ange
justement n'est pas lui qui a dit qu'il
fallait facile patrimoine on pourrait
justement c'est j'allais dire utiliser
ce patrimoine pour rappeler que à une
époque il avait des dérives qui ont
conduit qui on compte
il est rappelé ce qui se passe
actuellement avec les réfugiés et que
maintenant les arméniens soit une
communauté qui a contribué
considérablement y compris la défense de
la france avec le réseau manouchian qui
est venu justement de c2c de ces
réfugiés qu'on est censé protéger je
rejoins que la bleue
le premier sujet non mais ça serait une
manière de parler de la situation des
réfugiés actuellement et mais
effectivement il servira pas on va pas
détruire on a vu le maquereau allait
également à la ferme et voltaire on
oublie trop souvent il ya des écrits
objectivement ignoble de voltaire
notamment sur les mêmes missions sur le
fond les juges ont été exhumés notamment
par roger pol droit mais par contre un
petit mot sur la méthode
encore une fois il fins a encore soif
c'est une loterie nous on se met contre
cette année contre cette proposition est
ce que c'est une loterie
au lieu d'avoir un financement d'état
parce que les d'austérité auprès d'un
autre hic ça vous l'avez déjà georges et
la semaine dernière je connais votre
position sur l'auteur du pacte ont juste
un mois je te raconterai extrêmement
bien ce loto du patrimoine parce qu'on
sait très bien il suffit de se balader
sur pierre loti pour voir écouter sur
pierre loti alors là c'est vraiment la
désintégration neuronale de ce pays je
veux dit alors si on commence comme ça
on prend tous les auteurs il n'y a pas
un auteur depuis le siècle qui n'a pas
eu sur tel ou tel
ou telle population c'étaient les
préjugés de l'époque s'était voltaire
sur mahomet vous en parliez les juifs
mais c'est tous les autres molière vous
avez dans molière des phrases qui ne
parlent qu'ils ne passeraient pas alors
on va enlever molière on va enlever
toute notre vie tout y est dit et tout
ça c'est l'idéologie terrifiant de du
passé faisons table rase
au nom des ddd mentale natalité
soi-disant du présent on veut raser le
reste c'est lamentable bien loti il a
une très belle maison on garde
et puis si on n'a pas envie de pierre
loti qu on ne lit pas pire l'outil ça
s'appelle la liberté
je suis assez d'accord cette maison elle
est juste magnifique
pierre loti a été un officier de marine
qui s'est beaucoup inspiré de tout ce
qu'il a pu voir et café une maison
complètement incroyable avec beaucoup de
deux d'arabesques en de références
arabes etc
cette maison elle est juste incroyable
surtout là où elle est située voilà là
on parle de patrimoine
ensuite il ya le pierre loti qui s'est
également inspiré ses voyages pour être
écrivain
il n'a pas dit que des choses très
belles mais c'est pas en effaçant cette
maison qu'on va effacer sa mémoire il
est il est préférable qu'on connaisse
ses textes pour pouvoir les juger pour
pouvoir les décortiquer les analyser et
savoir ce qu'ils valent
plutôt que d'effacer une maison 20 jeudi
à sanaa céline on sait ce qui les
écrivent mais il crise on va supprimer
le voyage au bout de la nuit
alors comme ça on est dans le ragot et
adra devant sa défense absolutiste de
l'urss
ce qu'il faut si il ne faut plus
enseignée aragon l'école c'est le
s'ajuster n'importe quoi mais ça m'a
beaucoup servi une citation merci merci
beaucoup au revoir
inauguration sur figaro live de
l'exposition at light c'est au grand
palais de la saison au grand palais
c'est lors de lorsqu'en de la saison
france-israël et ça sera aussi en direct
sur figaro live dans un instant vous
avez rendez-vous être conversation marie
loeb laetitia bonavita reçoit jacques
attali et vous retrouvez demain point de
vue avec guillaume roquette bonne soirée
sur figaro live
[Musique]